now within 24 hours Amash got a primary
challenger michigan state Rep Jim lower
representative lower joins me now
exclusively now Hamas has been in
Congress for nearly a decade so why do
you think mr. lower that you can defeat
him over this one comment just one
comment it's a little I word well
there's a lot more that we can we can
talk about other than that comment but
it's more than just a comment he's
calling for our president to be
impeached and he doubled down on it
today I saw that he doubled down on
those comments saying that the Moller
report indicated that he should be
impeached there's nobody besides Bob
Moeller that would have loved to come
out with that conclusion and even he
couldn't come to that conclusion it's
completely ridiculous you know at this
point Justin Amash is more in common
with rashida to leave than he does the
average Republican primary voter in the
district so we are gonna beat him on
this issue we're also gonna beat him on
the fact that in 10 years in Congress
he's gotten one bill passed and it was
to rename a post office completely
ineffective
now Hamas was asked about all this let's
watch you I feel very confident in my
just very condescending it's not serious
are you serious tonight mister lower 100
percent serious in fact you know when
vote Lauer calm that's vote L o wer calm
launched thousands of dollars started
pouring in from all around the district
all around the state of Michigan and
throughout the country so it's a 100
percent serious campaign I have one
heart campaigns in the past and we're
gonna win this one too now in the past
by the way and and more was written
about this today
he's been dogged by his connections with
China's financial interests in China
Chinese companies and I think that's
part of it too
like the libertarians are fine if we
have to sell that sell America out to
the to the Red Chinese for you know for
the like soybeans or for some high-tech
equipment that is Soviet that's the
so-called free market so I think that's
probably gonna be another thing that
we're gonna look into and I think you're
serious so will we wish you all the best
thanks for being with us and
yeah you know if you look at he's the
only Republican in Congress to have
voted against funding for the border
while he's very weak on immigration
issues he's he's just freaking on basic
pro-life issues - yeah he's in the world
it's so our core platform he's weak on
I'm strong on it and that's why I'm
gonna beat him in the fall all right
thank you very much